somebody please is this Ebola is this
Ebola hey guys since we're all in
quarantine because of this coronavirus
pandemic I thought there's no better
time to watch a house m.d. episode about
a quarantine
[Music]
get hurt ow
what was in that jar
this acting is awful smallpox was
eradicated over 30 years ago
so our hush puppies may be checked out
your local hipster coffee shop lately
smallpox doesn't exist outside of p4
labs and bioweapon plants so that's
actually true I believe there's only
four labs or four locations in the world
that have samples of smallpox still
available for testing because we felt
like there would still be worthwhile
evidence that we can collect from how
this virus spreads how we can eradicate
it we've limited because of the fear of
bioterrorism
she wasn't Bermuda where she was scuba
diving on the wreck of a Dutch slave
ship that had been intentionally sunk
because an epidemic of smallpox had
broken out on board house always
presents himself shouldn't know these
just absurd things how does he know that
she was in the shipwreck like I want to
be in the room where he's questioning
his patients when a patient comes into
my office they have high fever vomiting
I don't ask if they've been on a pirate
ship lately like I just can't imagine
how he attracts that bit of information
thanks for calling back
listen I'm a screenwriter and is it
theoretically possible for smallpox just
survived for more than 200 years
underwater in a sealed glass jar thank
you
you mad you just call the CDC and ask
random questions like that isolate get
baseline blood drawers for smallpox
antibodies and vaccinate the entire
family okay first of all I can't imagine
what lab is gonna do smallpox testing
nowadays it has to be ascendant test to
Atlanta for the CDC headquarters are
theirs I don't have tests for that in my
office especially on my epic the
electronic medical record I think I
might put in smallpox there's gonna be
some major alert to tell me to contact
the CDC we should test for the 21st
century suspects varicella and measles
are free to perform whatever unnecessary
tests you want Foreman in all honesty
Foreman here is a hundred thousand
percent correct if a young woman
presents to the office with high fever
vomiting and bloodshot eyes you should
rule out everything that it's most
likely to be well first anything that's
most likely to be deadly smallpox should
be way way way low on the list of
differential diagnosis when I think
about that old school saying when you
hear hoofbeats you should think horses
not zebras
because thinking about zebras you missed
some pretty important cases that
are easily treatable liked influenza
virus like measles why the hell do you
guys have us quarantined in here we're
just taking every precaution against
what so I think this is a great time to
explain the difference between isolation
and quarantine isolation is when you
take someone who is sick and diagnosed
sick with a specific virus or bacteria
and you keep them isolated from other
people there's different forms of
isolation droplet airborne contact what
have you then if you're wondering if
someone has potentially been exposed by
something they may or may not be sick
they can be held in quarantine not
isolation that's what I'm doing here I'm
technically in quarantine because I'm
not sick I may or may not become sick
but that's what we're all doing social
distancing that does not look like
tetanus shots it's really not worth
going into because the odds are
astronomical
again it smallpox smallpox that would
have been really awesome if she just
said you know what you should do you
should stay alert not anxious I've been
really proud of the house empty shell
from doing that negative a virus a lot
of measles so all of our ideas are off
the table I'm putting mine back on
here's is a diver under increased
pressure everything that blood gets
scared panics runs in at high antibodies
could be in the joints of our knee ankle
shoulder many other joining her smallpox
ringing body doing a joint aspiration to
check if it is in fact smallpox seems
kind of dangerous there are a true times
where you need to do a joint aspiration
like if a patient has septic arthritis
and you need to culture the joint fluid
to see what antibiotics you should use
or if you're looking for gout but just
to do it on the off chance that she may
or may not have smallpox that actually
puts the patient at risk for septic
arthritis which is a bacterial infection
of the joint oh no what does he see
what is it I'm sorry I have to call the
CDC I don't know I think you do have
smallpox
boisterous let's take a look at this
what is it who's a rash into your
daughter's arm like more of those gross
bumps no it's just a regular rash what
does that mean he's just not smallpox I
don't know why not cuz that could still
can be a smallpox rash House explain it
to me I'm doctor Broudy
head of infection control CDC and your
protective suits are not adequate turns
out they don't have to be rash under the
arm means it's not smallpox false alarm
sorry hope the traffic wasn't too bad
rash is consistent with smallpox not if
it presents after pustules
he's probably just allergic to the
bedsheets of the hospital gown oh you
simply didn't notice it we're gonna
airlift blood and tissue samples to
Atlanta we'll have the DNA results in 18
hours in the meantime please step out of
the room it's funny I find myself
agreeing with the CDC doctor more than I
am with dr. house but I know it's
probably too my demise
[Music]
sir are you feeling all right in there
she's just the head a child no his eyes
[Music]
dead you're bleeding somebody please is
this Ebola is this Ebola when this
stopped why did you stop get out of the
hallway he does not have smallpox yes he
does it chief
he's just developed pustules he's now
too dangerous to transport the virus
that causes smallpox is called variola
and before we had vaccinations we used
to do valuation where you take a piece
of the pustule that people develop and
you introduce it to somebody in order to
inoculate them you need to get their
immune system ready to face the real
smallpox that wasn't as good as the
vaccines we are today we have today
because you actually got sick with
smallpox at that case however your case
wasn't as bad as those who caught it
naturally so this was a way to get sick
but not as sick as everyone else it was
only until we got the smallpox vaccine
we were we truly able to eradicate
smallpox from the world wait
there aren't any lesions no pustules on
the daughter's palms so so therefore
your theory is you asked me to take the
dad's blood but I accidentally injected
him with smallpox exactly although
technically was the vaccinia virus just
what the smallpox vaccine is made from
same symptom this is smallpox but only
half the calories and almost none of the
lethality you sound like one of those
anti vaccine cranks you can't develop
full-blown symptoms when the vaccine is
quickly yeah if you're a team you know
compromise I'm the only one who reads
these things dad at kidney cancer six
years ago he's been in remission well
it's obviously back I swear our house
just walks around and throws diagnosis
on everyone that could be possible and I
feel like he does this so inaccurately
that he has such a low success rate it
doesn't matter it's at the end of the
day each time he gets proven wrong he'll
figure us
else that he can throw out there and
he'll be right not a fan of this
approach not very realistic you got any
proof the kidney cancer is back well let
me give him this but he gets better
that'll be the proof you need I'll put
on one of your fancy spacesuits and I
promise it won't kiss him on an open
sore you know Janet Parker is that's the
last person who died of smallpox in 1978
she was working at a university in
England someone in a research lab in the
floor below screwed up some smallpox
virus managed to float up through the
vents into the room where she was
working she died four days later
last known person to die from smallpox
and the person in charge of the lab was
so destroyed he killed himself
well did I know that now that he's
shedding I can't open that door for any
more when he says now that he's shedding
he's talking about the pustules that is
the most infectious stage of smallpox so
you don't want to be anywhere near a
person if they truly do have it Hey oh
no house Hey this is textbook smallpox
de Xing at this point it isn't gonna
make a difference don't say that I'm
sorry house
you screwed up going in there
[Music]
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions even house fails us
with the chest compressions he's
starting get the defibrillator ready
instead of doing chest compressions I
know he's not by himself but still and
I'm pretty sure the rhythm I saw pop up
there was flatline
you don't shock flatline either house
you know better than that if the cat get
sick smallpox is exclusive to human is
this toxoplasmosis pets
nothing and nobody went on though ships
if it didn't have a purpose hunting mice
and rats for the crew the hold was
probably infested with mice what if
that's the difference what happened to
hair it is that a sad R or a cute arm
Kennedy died sad ah before he died did
he lose his fur
how did you know
mice don't carry smallpox but they do
carry rickettsialpox
my knowledge of Rickettsia pox is not
up-to-date Rickettsia pox is a mild
self-limited zoonotic febrile illness
characterized by a scar formation at the
location of a mite bite following the
onset of systemic symptoms in a more
generalized papular vesicular rash
rickettsialpox occurs primarily in urban
areas where density of mites mice and
humans is high they named it in 1946 in
New York City NYC in about 2007 there's
been 14 cases reported approximately 1.7
cases per million people that's why I
haven't seen it at least look at the
dad's body small patches of black dead
tissue would prove I'm right
s cars appear with Rickettsia pox but
not with smallpox he had developed s
cars I would have noticed
as gone
s cars scars is dead tissue on the body
you frequently see it with apps to seize
meaning when someone has a pocket of
infection but it's very common appearing
of where the patient was bitten by a
mite in our pox start the girl on
doxycycline right now
I still would have take off my gear like
that oh my god just cuz you saw that s
car could have been caused by anything
my god this is ridiculous
infection control people this would
never happen in any hospital ever ever
ever if this truly happened in this
matter in a hospital house would still
be kept under quarantine just in case he
didn't have another infectious condition
because god forbid you left them you let
him out too early and now he's walking
around infecting all the future patients
he sees in his colleagues no way no no
way if you're a fan of house m.d. I put
together a playlist of my house m.d.
reviews there's been a few I also have a
bunch of others so search them on my
channel dr. Mike with your favorite show
where dr. Mike with a medical condition
the results will pop up and surprise you
I'm curious where you're going to be
happy and healthy